hello everyone and welcome back to round
nine uh or rather welcome back to norway
chess 2021 it's around nine and we have
a really really crazy game between
rickard and yani
uh robert still leading the tournament
and their classical game ended very very
quickly and that's why i'm already
presenting their armageddon game since
both of them ended very very quickly and
this game features an incredible opening
and then even more incredible moments so
you guys will have a very enjoyable
positive video moment and then we're
going to discuss the rest of the game as
usual
but uh you know it's um
just uh
just so crazy but
you'll see what i mean by this uh so a
rapport with the white pieces opens with
knight to f3 so uh he goes for the retti
opening and uh this is uh his chance to
get back at nepal because if you
remember in the first half of the
tournament uh their classical game was
also drawn but nepal won the armageddon
with white so now rapper has a chance
with white to do something about this so
knight to f3 uh going for diretti
opening we have d5 and now d3 yeah this
is not the way uh one would usually go
about it it's the old indian attack uh
we have g6 and now knight b to d2
preparing e4 and then white wants to
bring the knight to c4 uh bishop to g7
yep of enquires the dark square bishop
e4 and now knight to c6 and now uh there
are some games where g3 was played also
c3 is a known move but the movie rapper
plays e captures and d5 is a new move so
already as of move 5 we have a
completely new game usually not
something you want to play because you
already developed the knight to d2 so if
queen captures on d5
like for example in the scandinavian
defense you don't have the standard
knight to see three gaining the tempo on
the queen uh but okay queen captures on
the five and now g3 preparing uh
tafianka to the light square bishop and
then we're gonna have some indirect
pressure towards the black queen so
knight to f6 by nipple bishop to g2 and
now we have queen to e6 with check
saying uh okay this is armageddon if we
draw the game then i win the match so
you either play queen to e2 and uh then
i don't even have to trade right away i
can play knight before go after your c
two pawn and this will be very very
problematic for you uh or you have to
play king to f1 but this is not a
problem for rapport as he would have
probably played king to f1 regardless of
what black plays so here nipple castles
to safety and now knight to c4 so a very
very nicely placed knight here uh and
now what do you do the knight placed on
c4 although it's uh really nicely placed
it's uh it's an imprecision by rapport
and nipple can take advantage of it with
rook to d8 yeah because it already
introduces the threat of queen captures
on c4 uh because if pawn captures rook
captures on d1 would check so a slight
imprecision but hard to pick up in such
a quick paced game
like in armageddon so here nipple just
goes back with the queen queen to d7 uh
we have bishop to d2 shifting the bishop
over to c3 and now queen to d8 nipple
says all right i can see you're going
really crazy here slow down i just want
to play a normal calm game and get
myself you know maybe a draw maybe more
but you know we don't want to we don't
want anything too crazy because he knows
how
uh
you know accomplished of a player a
rapport is so bishop to c3 and now
bishop to e6 now again you have some
plans of maybe captures captures and
then trading queens as a draw is
sufficient for you so queen to e2 and
now rook to e8 uh we have rook to e1 now
with ideas of uh just advancing this
pawn and the king will remain on f1
maybe on g1 at some point uh queen to c8
preparing bishop to h3 to trade off the
light square bishops and that operate of
course goes h4 and doesn't allow it now
both the rook and the bishop guard the
h3 square and if of course plays h5 he
doesn't want to allow any further
expansion from white on the on the king
side uh knight to g5 now putting
pressure on the bishop here and the
bishop to g4 attacking robert's queen
queen to d2 and now nipple says all
right my pieces are kind of nicely
placed here i just have to you know
continue my development and he played
queen to d7 but queen to d7 is a move
that blunders the entire game it's hard
to imagine that such a thing is possible
in a position like this
but it's all i'm not going to spoil it
for you uh
better just pause the video and try to
figure it out for yourself
so while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh amazing opportunity that white got in
an armageddon game against the world
church championship challenger and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course knight captures on
f7 and now look at this what do you play
here uh if king captures on f7 if you
don't capture the knight then i mean you
just lost the f7 pawn and you allowed
this knight this beautiful infiltrating
move then ideas like knight six check
are possible so black is just uh uh
terrible here i mean he has no defenses
left in front of his king or this pawn
is now weak this pawn will become weak
and uh so you would have to capture the
knight i mean you can't capture it you
lose the game but you lose the game
whatever you play but the point is if
king captures knight to e5 check wins
the queen yes the black knight on c6 is
covering that uh but we just pick up the
knight bishop captures on c6 and that's
it uh black queen cannot capture because
if you capture the knight of the e5
check wins the queen and if you don't
capture you just uh you know
you're just completely busted what do
you play there there's really nothing
you can't play here you could play some
like queen to f5 queen back to d8 it
doesn't really matter we can capture
here on b7 so everything is just falling
apart here for black you can go to b8
and then we can play knight the e5 with
check just really really ugly king can
go here bishop to c6 it's uh it's a
complete mess of a position but white of
course is just much much better here and
there's there there's really nothing for
black to do here uh so knight captures
an f7 a beautiful move that
unfortunately rapport missed um as well
first of all it's a very quick timeform
at armageddon seven versus ten minutes
and on the other hand you don't uh
expect nepot to miss something like this
so you're not even looking for it which
is something that every chess player um
uh you know tends to to make a mistake
on but you know it's just uh
this is just what happens so here after
queen to d7 we have knight backed uh
we have knight back the e3 attacking
black's bishop here and now rook eight
to d8 and now yep's position is
perfectly fine we have b4 that up
so in a couple of my previous videos
that b4 is often a winning move for
white so of course he attempts this uh
and now you could try a lot of things
like e5 for example if b5 then knight to
d4 is very strong but he goes for knight
to d for right away and now what do you
play here well we don't want to allow
this knight to remain here we have to
constantly keep an eye on this knight to
f3 move okay for the moment not possible
but it's in just a nuisance so bishop
captures and seeth
on the four queen captures on d4 and now
bishop captures on b7 so rapport's still
getting a lot out of the position
queen to h6 by nipple and now knight
captures on g4 we have knight captures
and queen to f4 he now offers a queen
trade and hopes to retain his extra pawn
nipple says that's not happening we're
gonna trade queens but you are not
keeping your pawn uh g captures and now
e6 and now his plan is to just bring the
rook over here and then uh will threaten
both of these pawns so here we have
bishop the c6 attacking the rook here
but now rook back to f8
you could also go rook to a7 but still
you will not be able to double up so
rook to f8
and now comes b5 so this pawn will not
be a problem if this row comes to d4 but
still just rook to d4 going after the f4
pawn so of course rapper defends it rook
to e4 and now rook f2 d8
and now what do you play well there's
really no good way to to
improve with white here maybe idea like
rook to h3 but it still uh looks very
odd what is the rook uh actually doing
there so here we have knight to f3
attacking black's rook and kind of
forcing black to capture on e4 rook
capture sunny for bishop capture e4 and
now of course we recapture our missing
pawn bishop captures on f4 and now the
material is completely equal and we have
bishops of opposite color on the board
so everything uh is looking favorable
for nipple to get at least a draw in
this game king e2 we have knight to f6
and now a4 uh we have king to f8 and now
rook to a1 trying to create some chances
here on the queen side king to e7 now
comes a5 and now king to d6 of course
it's important to activate our king in
the end game knight to d4 and now comes
knight captures on e4 here a very nice
idea for nipple might be bishop to a5
just saying okay this is not
working out at all for me uh but he goes
for knight captures on e4 d captures an
e4 and now king to c5 attacking the
knight here and if the knight moves of
course the b5 pawn so knights the c6
offering this pawn for a rook and of
course we will move the rook rook d to
check king to f3 and now that your
bishop is attacked by the just king
captures on b5 you say okay you capture
the bishop i'm going to capture the
knight rapport first grabs the a7 pawn
with the check now he has a pass pawn
here if the knight moves it could be
very dangerous king to a6 of course
nipple will block the past pawn with his
king knight to c6 and now of course we
have to uh get our bishop to safety so
bishop to d6 and now our c2 pawn is
hanging and what do you do here well
here we have c3 uh it's not a lot but uh
rapport
had to play something you could also try
some other ideas maybe something like
knight to b8 with check trying to get
the king away from this a6 square but
then king to b7 and you still don't have
a
way of pushing this pawn if you play
rook to b1 check we still just play king
to a7 uh and now okay what do you play
you can play a6 but then you still lose
the c2 pawn and you really haven't made
any progress here
if the rook moves to help out with the
defense of the pawn you lose the knight
if the knight moves you lose the pawn so
there is no way to do anything with this
pass pawn so instead after bishop to d6
rapper tried c3 but this just runs into
not that obviously some mouse slip rook
to d3 check kinked the g2 and now rook
captures on c3 putting pressure on the
knight knight to d8 now going after the
base of the pawn chain and now f5 uh we
have e5 now attacking the bishop trying
to get the bishop to capture then we
play rook to e1 and go after the e6 pawn
so bishop captures on e5 rook to e1 and
now bishop to d4 uh rook captures an e6
with check but now now of course you
don't to grab the a5 pawn you could
still blunder the game it's not a
problem just knight to c6 check now you
either lose the bishop
or you have to give up the rook so
some something would happen there uh so
after rook captures an e6 we have king
to b5 by nipple and now it upward
finally gets to push his pass pawn pawn
to a6 but now rook the seat going after
the f2 pawn uh and now the a7 square is
covered by the bishop so you can't
really push that either and there is no
way to
actually achieve uh anything here so
king the f1 was played trying to get the
king uh at least closer to that queen
side rook captures on f2 with track king
to e1 and now rook to a2 just a very
principled putting the rook behind the
pass pawn maneuver rook captures on g6
now comes root captures on a6 rook to g5
and here we have king to c4 and it was
in this position animal 49 that rapport
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh it's just uh
well okay you could grab some pawns here
but let's say you grab a pawn you create
your own pass pawn king to d3 and now
look at this the king covers all of
these squares the bishop covers this uh
there's no defense rook day one
checkmate is coming uh and it's just
very ugly you could prolong it of course
with king to f1 but once uh you know the
the black king and bishop get such a
nice grip on the opponent's king there's
simply no playing this and of course
both of them notice and rapport of
course resigns
so a really nice game by both of them
rapport together that beautiful chance
but like i said you do not expect to be
you know uh
given such a gift by the world
championship challenger in this position
that we discussed just i mean uh it's
move 16 uh queen to d2 queen to d7 and
now for knight captures an f7 to even be
a possibility it's simply insane but it
was in the position and uh it's a pretty
you know big shame that uh he he
couldn't find it but you know who who
would expect such a thing from nepal
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it we're going to cover the other games
as well and only then discuss the
standings uh i would like to thank tom
derelo isaac uh hits the graph francis
heir sirigoto yoshila and chet as
blunderful for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and it would
seem that nipple both won both of uh
his encounters with rihard rapport see
you soon guys